hey 42 here as of 2015 there were
roughly 4,200 religions in the world
some are thousands of years old and
there are new ones being created all the
time he is seven extremely bizarre
religions that sound completely made-up
but they're not let's begin with the
biggest religion on our list
in 2001 thanks to each country
completing a census of their populations
this religion was found to be the second
biggest in New Zealand and the fourth
biggest in England and Wales any guess
as to what it might be strange the
answer is its Jedi yes around 1.5
percent of Kiwis put Jedi or Jediism as
their official religion 58.9% called
christian and then the next two spots
were no religion and object to answering
so that pushed Jediism as the number two
religion in new zealand unless object to
answering Gizem religion there's
probably no point in asking them if it
is low in England and Wales 0.8 percent
of the country claimed that their
religion was Jediism with the only
larger face being Christianity Islam and
Hinduism so how did this all come about
a long long time ago in a country not
very far away the Galactic Council I
mean the national governments of many
Commonwealth countries let everyone know
that they would be having a census many
people on the internet decided that they
didn't want to tell the government about
their religion and so one of the first
online viral phenomena began of people
spreading the idea of saying that they
were Jedi on their census when you look
at their beliefs it's actually you're
pleasantly positive they obviously
believe in the force and the inherent
worth of all life within it and much of
the rest is just about not
discriminating being logical and I'm
guessing here never ever talking about
the Phantom Menace in public their
doctrines have actually allowed them to
be a fully recognised international
ministry and a publicly registered
charity so if you've got some
galactic credits lying around you know
where to send them there are some people
who you can imagine being mistaken for
God's Ryan Gosling with his annoyingly
handsome face chess champion Bobby
Fischer with his godlike intelligence
and quick thinking or maybe Hugh Jackman
if you saw him chopping wood high up on
a mountain but none of these people have
an actual religious following the
unlikely man who does however is Prince
Philip Duke of Edinburgh and husbands to
queen elizabeth ii and his followers are
not some extreme British nationalists
they are in fact inhabitants of a small
island halfway across the world called
tonic part of the Republic of Vanuatu
Vanuatu is a chain of islands in the
South Pacific just under 2,000
kilometers east of northern Australia
Tana is one of the 82 odd Islands and is
populated mainly of Melanesians Pacific
island people of similar origin to the
Australian Aboriginals an old myth
exists on the island about a spirit
ancestor who had run off across the seas
to find himself a powerful wife so when
Prince Phillip visited the island in
1974 almond armed with her royal Majesty
one of the most powerful women in the
world
they decided that he fitted the bill
perfectly and declared him to be their
God I imagine he enjoyed a similar fate
as c-3po did under the hospitality of
the Ewoks during his visit to Endor
Prince Phillip being the affable man
that he is sent them a signed photograph
in return they sent him a club for
killing pigs I can neither confirm nor
deny of this had any connection to the
increase in bacon consumption at
Buckingham Palace that year profit Jack
the Prince Phillip movements soo same
religious leader has claimed that a
devastating cyclone which came to the
island in early 2015 was a holy sign
that the Great Prince himself will be
returning to the island in 2016 we'll
just have to wait and see so for our
next religion we have to travel all the
way to actually we don't need to travel
at all we're staying on the island of
Tanna
Vanuatu has a number of cargo cults
these are Melanesian movements that
originated from the native people coming
into contact with decolonizing societies
who visited the island
antara about 50% of the population are
part of the cargo cult called John from
which allegedly started with the visions
of some elders in the late 1930s and
became cemented when the American troops
came during world war ii the name is
said to confirm when a soldier told the
natives that he was John from America
the people saw all a wonderful cargo
that these troops brought such as
Larry's radios and the world's most
iconic brand coca-cola when the soldiers
left the people knew that John frum
would surely return someday and share
his wonderful bounty with them all in a
way they were right since the island now
boasts an airport and some
infrastructure for education as well as
a variety of Western brands the people
are very grateful and they share evenly
amongst their community February the
15th is known as John from day the date
which they believe John frum will return
to the island they celebrate John from
they with a military like parade
marching through the island carrying the
Stars and Stripes and scrolling qsa on
their chests in red paint throwing some
fireworks and beer pong gannets
basically the 4th of July
our next religion is followed by a large
number of atheists I know what you're
thinking how can you have a religion for
people who don't believe in religion
well the pastafarians have a pretty good
reason Pastafarianism came about in 2005
when Bobby Henderson discussed the
Flying Spaghetti Monster in an open
letter to the Kansas State Board of
Education this God is a sort of floating
blob of wobbly noodles and meatballs if
this all sounds very silly it's supposed
to be he came up with the idea in order
to fight against a decision to allow
creationism to be taught in schools
thanks to the campaigning of Christian
groups for those of you not familiar
with the argument atheists agree with
the large consensus of scientists who
believe that the universe is around
14 billion years old with earth being
formed around four and a half billion
years ago and that life has grown and
diversified through evolution with the
smallest amoebas eventually leading to
the pinnacle of human evolution
creationists believe that God created
the world around ten thousand years ago
and that each creature was made as it is
now it's called intelligent design and
it argues against evolution pastafarians
beef and whatever other meats there
noodley deity contains with creationism
being taught in schools is that it
violates the secular nature of the laws
of the USA there is supposed to be a
complete separation of church and state
and this includes schools creationism is
a religious idea specific to a few
religions not to all of them therefore
it shouldn't be a part of state
education to prove this Bobby Henderson
argued that he believes a supernatural
Italian dinner was the world Creator and
that whenever a scientist tried to
carbon-date an object to see how old it
was this God was there
changing the result with his noodly
appendage he said his beliefs we're just
as valid as creationists and therefore
should be included in the curriculum as
well seems fair the idea took hold and
spread around the internet and the
church at a Flying Spaghetti Monster has
many followers allegedly leading back to
pirates who were the original
pastafarians I'm sure you'll all be very
worried to know that they figure decline
in the number of pirates is a direct
cause of global warming
only the release of another 18 Jack
Sparrow films will start to reverse this
trend I presume so from extra pasta
sauce to extraterrestrials let's have a
look at one of many UFO religions that
sprung up in the second half of the 20th
century universe people also called
cosmic people of light powers is a group
that believed a fleet of spaceships
float around the earth where they subtly
intervene in the lives of the god
assisting them on their way and someday
the ashtar galactic command you'll lead
to ships
we'll pick up the believers and send
them off to another wonderful dimension
most of the followers are based in the
Czech Republic and Slovakia thanks to
the religions founder Ivo a bender whose
name sounds somewhat like the punchline
to a politically incorrect joke in 1997
he published the delightfully titled
interviews with instructions from my
friends from the universe and he used it
as a platform to begin touring with a
series of public lectures he eventually
made his way onto national TV in both
the Czech Republic and Slovakia in the
late 2000s bender began to realize that
the alien world much like Earth
contained both helpful and harmful
people the saurians or lizard people
were out to get us and bender was going
to do all he could to stop them it was
all very reminiscent of the classic
Czech novel war with news by Karel Capek
where the salamanders end up turning on
mankind in 2007 then this plan caused a
security alert and the Slovak Ministry
of Defence when his suspicious
protection packages arrived containing
instructional CDs and promotional
material what if a man can't protect his
country from large alien lizards with a
recorded lecture and some fliers then
how else is he supposed to do it he
still fights the good fight and you can
see what he's up to on his website
universe - people.com just to warn you
you might want to put on sunglasses
before you enter it's more colorful and
a teenage unicorn sock collection now
I'm not saying blizzard people are real
but if they are I'm pretty sure our next
religious leader is one of them happy
science was founded in 1986 by the
Robert reptilian-looking ryuou Ark our
he had read an inspiring series of books
by Takahashi Shinji no I'm not talking
about the baseball player but the other
famous Takahashi Shinji who is leader of
the God light Association the books had
a big impact on mr. Ark our and made him
see that he was actually the living
embodiment of among governs Christ
Buddha and Allah
a tough decision what he realized that
since he was an omnipotent super God
he was probably overqualified for his
job at a large Japanese trading company
so he resigned and began spreading the
good word that he was in fact the great
super deity el cantare the fact that
this means the singer in Spanish is just
a cosmic coincidence to be a happy
scientist you need to focus on the four
fold paths of love wisdom
self-reflection and progress no actual
scientific knowledge is required so
don't worry have you forgotten all your
chemistry you might need to forget some
of your history though as Alcantara has
told us that certain parts of Japanese
history such as the odd massacre or two
definitely didn't happen the politics
don't end there since the political wing
called the happiness realization party
was set up in 2009 and received a rather
surprising 1 million votes across
Japan's three hundred constituencies
they didn't end up with any seats though
the main focus of their campaign was to
double the Japanese population and to
develop a nuclear deterrent to threaten
China and North Korea they really don't
like China and North Korea I'm not sure
nuclear weapons are exactly what I would
call happy science but hey I'm not the
flamenco god of the universe so what do
I know right
our final religion has a much darker
history than the others it's all fun and
games when it's British princes
lizard-men
and Alcantara but when you're cold leads
to murder and mass suicide that's a
whole different story the order of the
solar temple was set up in 1984 by
Joseph di Mambro and Luc Jouret and was
a continuation of other groups Daman bro
had been in and founded in the previous
decade or so they started out in
Switzerland and moved to a headquarters
in Quebec Canada in the late 80s the
religion was based on a mix of sources
the main one being the famous Knights
Templar
their idea was to reassert the correct
balance of power in the world and to lay
the way for the second coming of Christ
the solar king they also took
inspiration from notorious British
occultist Aleister Crowley the oddest
dark sight was revealed to the world on
October 1994 with deaths on both sides
of the Atlantic a couple and a young
baby were killed in Quebec with rumors
that Dammam bro had accused a child of
being the Antichrist a few days later in
Switzerland
both demon bro and sureiy were found
dead along with 46 other cult members
not only that but the bodies were
discovered arranged in a disturbing Sun
shaped pattern on the floor the true
story will never be uncovered but many
of the group had been drugged some were
shot some suffocated with bags over
their heads and both buildings were on
fire unfortunately it didn't end with
the death of the founders and there were
further mass killings in 95 and 97 it
transpired that mass murders and group
ritual suicide were all part and parcel
of being a member of the order of the
solar temple no Franks I think I'm going
to go join the Jedi instead thanks for
the view subscribe for more 46
you